meu amigo que calor é esse euu Eu não
sei o que que tá acontecendo com a
camada de Antônio eu tô doente a um lado
respira outro ó mais entupido que depois
que come banana verde aí tô tomando
muita água porque eu tô gripado aí
aliado esse calor do cão aqui também
Toda vez você pergunta para alguém é
[__] tô gripado tô doente a pessoa faz
S beber muita água digo eu vou virar um
caminhão pipa porque mais água que eu
rab eu tô para fazer igual aqueles
maratonista não e as piadas que eu tenho
que aguentar ainda um calor do cão aqui
em São Paulo digo eu tô com sede a
pessoa contra outra né Wind tu tá com
sede [__] tu é acostumado com isso Tu é
do
Piauí Conta outra eu digo sim meu filho
eu sou do Piauí eu não sou um camelo nem
o camelo gosta meu amigo de calor é
porque ele não fala no dia que o camelo
começar a falar a primeira frase que ele
fala
faz me leva pra Europa eu nasci no calor
sim eu tenho costume de frio não 22 G já
tô ao redor de uma fogueira assando
marshmallow sim mas não quer dizer que
eu gosto de calor